[Musique]
avec vous Hélène Fred bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline vous avez lu les
journaux pour nous et les réactions donc
au premier tour des législatives ici en
France ou la nupeste Damien disait à
l'instant est au coude à coudre avec la
majorité présidentielle et le premier
tour de ces législatives est également
marqué Damien Lady par une abstention
record près de 52 et demi pour cent un
niveau d'abstention que le quotidien La
Croix voit non pas comme la preuve du
désintérêt des Français pour la
politique mais comme la manifestation de
leur frustration je cite devant
l'absence de prise en compte des
situations d'injustice et de leurs
sentiments que leur préoccupation ne
sont pas traitées Emmanuel Macron a fait
le pari d'une campagne atone persuadée
que l'abstention jour est en sa faveur
c'était se tromper de diagnostic écrit
le journal votre quotidien même verdict
un revers graves pour le président dixit
le Figaro qui voit le camp présidentiel
se diriger vers une majorité étriquée à
l'Assemblée en tentant de chlor former
toute la campagne par calcul tactique ou
hésitation stratégiques Emmanuel Macron
n'aura réussi qu'à nourrir l'abstention
et étouffer dans l'oeuf la dynamique que
la présidentielle aurait pu créer en sa
faveur l'opinion finit d'enfoncer le
clou preuve est faite que l'absence de
proposition n'est pas une bonne
stratégie de campagne à force de parier
sur les effets positifs d'une abstention
de masse la majorité ensemble a laissé
le doute s'installer chez ses électeurs
avait-elle besoin de leur voix à gauche
donc Hélène la nupette s'emmenée par le
patron des insoumis Jean-Luc Mélenchon
fait réussir un tour de force même si
une cohabitation semble
à présent hors de portée d'après
libération le patron de la France
insoumise a réussi son pari de devenir
la principale force de position à
Emmanuel Macron mais probablement pas en
effet de s'imposer comme futur premier
ministre dans la mesure où la nuque a
peu de réserve de voie ce qui l'oblige à
se tourner vers les abstentionnistes aux
alentours convaincre les millions
d'électeurs qui ne se sont pas déplacés
au premier tour l'humanité veut croire
qu'une majorité de gauche est à portée
dure ne tout en reconnaissant que
l'objectif peut sembler difficile à
atteindre cette un euphémisme une
compense-t-on à l'étranger à l'image de
la presse française les quotidiens
étrangers et notamment le quotidien
espagnol et le mundo présente ses
résultats comme une punition infligée à
Emmanuel Macron en Allemagne le
Frankfurter alghai parle d'un
avertissement clair pour le chef de
l'État qui ne pourra probablement pas
obtenir à lui seul la majorité absolue
et de raconter sur le soutien de son
ancien Premier ministre Edouard Philippe
et son parti horizon mais également sur
le soutien de l'ancien ministre de la
Justice François Bayrou et du MoDem au
Liban L'Orient-Le Jour voit la macronie
secouer mais pas à terre et notre au
passage que le rassemblement national
n'a pas réussi à capitaliser sur la
dynamique de Marine Le Pen à la
présidentielle même si le de députés RN
devrait être nettement plus étoffée
après le second tour quoi qu'il en soit
l'opposition devrait être présente en
force dans la future rassemblée
nationale et le soir Pauline prédit déjà
que ça va tanguer au Palais Bourbon le
quotidien belge voit dans le réveil de
la gauche le signe que le temps est à
l'urgence sociale en France celui qui
avait été taxé de président des riches
dans un premier quinquennat ne pourra
pas miser que sur la théorie du
ruissellement je vais y arriver prévient
le quotidien belge Emmanuel Macron sur
un autre sujet Hélène dont la visite en
Ukraine la première depuis le début de
la guerre se précise d'après le World
c'est journal qui cite ici des sources
européennes le président français mais
également le chancelier allemand Olaf
Scholl c'est le premier ministre italien
Mario Draghi prévoit de se rendre jeudi
à Kiev un projet qui n'est toutefois pas
confirmé officiellement ce voyage s'il
est maintenu serait en effet le premier
en Ukraine depuis le début de la guerre
pour les dirigeants à un moment où les
Ukrainiens disent craindre un
affaiblissement du soutien
occidental selon en degardienne en
Russie les derniers chiffres officiels
sur les soldats tués en Ukraine remonte
au 25 mars dernier invite que des médias
ont tenté de combler en recensant et en
publiant les noms des disparus dans leur
région d'après Elena Trifonova qui est
la co-fondatrice d'un journal local de
bouriatis est une province qui se trouve
à 3000 km à l'est de Moscou au nord de
la Mongolie les autorités russes
cherchent désormais aussi à interdire
ces murs de la mémoire interrogés par le
quotidien suisse Le Temps cette
journaliste affirme que l'opération
spéciale comme on l'appelle en Russie
reste largement soutenu par la
population locale critiquer la guerre
explique-t-elle équivaut à dire que la
mort d'un parent d'un ami d'une
connaissance est inutile c'est une
impuissance apprise et les gens aussi
ont peur d'être seul contre tous
à propos de solitude et d'un puissance
Pauline le New York Time s'est demandé
comment précisément essayer de réparer
le monde de le rendre meilleur même à
petit échelle au niveau individuel bien
sûr les grandes choses comptes bien sûr
que le vote et la politique sont
importants mais certaines pratiques bien
que modestes sont profondément
significatives écrit le journal qui cite
par exemple le fait d'avoir des vraies
conversations avec autrui en présentiel
comme on dit maintenant les yeux dans
les yeux de sortir de chez soi d'ouvrir
un livre ou encore de se livrer un
exercice assez intéressant
rechercher les meilleurs arguments
utilisés par celles et ceux avec
lesquels nous ne sommes pas d'accord un
exercice qui demande à la fois curiosité
et humilité effectivement merci beaucoup
Hélène humidité à tout à l'heure dans
Paris direct